[Music]
lee is with us in omaha nebraska hi lee
how are you
i'm doing well dave how about you better
than i deserve what's up
well i want to give you a little quick
history i talked to you about five years
ago after reading the money makeover i
at that time i was three years away from
retirement
uh i called and told you that i had paid
off everything but my house and i wanted
to get an annuity in my ira to make my
house payment
and you advised me against that and told
me to take a withdrawal and pay off the
house
well against the advice of my friends i
did that so i've been debt free for the
last five years and it's a pretty darn
good feeling so i appreciate the advice
but
what's happening now is the same friends
are telling me i need an inflation hedge
and that i should withdraw money from my
ira and put money down on a couple of
rental properties so that they
increase in value over the next few
years
but my problem is i have quite a bit of
my ira in tips staggered so they come
due at different times and i bonds so
i'm making eight nine percent now i'm
only withdrawing three
so
my wife tells me why in the world would
you want to be a landlord and have leaky
toilets and calls in the middle of the
night and all that so
my question to you dave is do i listen
to my friends or do i listen to my wife
well that's a no-brainer
then we could talk about the advice too
but i mean
the proverb says who can find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her and he will have no lack
of gain
if your wife isn't a nag and she is a
wise virtuous woman
her worth her wisdom is will cause you
to have no lack of gain as opposed to
stupid friends
and there's lots of people have stupid
friends i've got a few stupid friends so
i'm sitting next to one though no i
don't know george is not stupid george
is a lot of things but stupid is not on
the list but i i i
agree i think you can ignore your
friend's advice on this one and not
because your wife is right and they're
wrong but what's because it's not it's
not a wise move for everyone now let's
talk about it for a second okay what is
a hedge
against inflation a hedge is literally
like you think of a a row of bushes
right
tightly woven together so that the
neighbor's dog can't get through right i
mean it's it's a blocker
a hedge is a blocker a wall
to keep inflation from getting in
all inflation hedges
are investments that invest in things
that inflate with inflation
so real estate is a hedge against
inflation
investing in companies whose stock goes
up and price goes up if the inflation
rate goes up uh would be a hedge against
inflation
energy company as an example
what happens what's a component of
inflation gas price at the pump right
right so if you buy a energy company you
have a hedge against inflation because
they're
they are inflation
and so you own a piece of inflation
thus it's a hedge real estate is
inflation
the rising real estate prices is a
component of inflation so that's a hedge
against inflation tips aren't
uh savings accounts aren't so if you
wanted to have a hedge against inflation
yes real estate would be a play
uh and a good one uh yes uh
moving some of your money into some
mutual funds
that are investing in stocks of
companies
that are gaining due to inflation
so you are riding the wave of inflation
rather than being crushed by it that is
the definition of a hedge that's the
essence of it and so but aren't pips
tied to inflation so
they could be depends on what's in it
well i mean i own tips uh within my ira
but i bought they were purchased as
bonds so it's not a tips fund it's
bonds are not
bonds are not because bonds are just a
debt instrument they've got a fixed
interest rate attached to them
and that is not a company maybe i'm
using the wrong term it's it's a
treasury inflated protected security
right is what it's called a tip so i
maybe it's a note maybe bond is the
wrong word well it is a note and but it
has a fixed coupon rate that's why it's
not a component of inflation see if you
think of okay lumber went up 3x during
covet right went from 600 dollars per
100 600 per board foot or whatever up up
to about 1500
and so in that that is a component of
inflation and so
if you owned uh a stock in a lumber
company if you were participating in 84
lumber i don't even know if it's
publicly traded but if it was and you
owned in that then you would be having a
hedge against inflation if you own
a note that 84 lumber company has
promised to pay eight percent on
it doesn't change with inflation
but the price of lumber changes and that
company makes more money
so you got to be participating as an
owner not a lender
i see and that that's what moves so if
you're concerned about that i would move
some of my portfolio and i probably
would anyway into some good mutual funds
now if you want to buy some real estate
and you want to pay cash for it and buy
real estate that doesn't require a lot
of leaky toilets and midnight calls i
mean you could buy a little small piece
commercial a little office building a
little apartment or something have
somebody else manage it that'd be okay
what's the size of your net worth
uh
well total with house ira everything
probably eight hundred thousand eight
fifty way to go congratulations how old
are you well
i am i'll be 68 shortly
after hearing you talk i'm probably
gonna sit exactly where you are i'm with
your wife
she's gonna be glad to hear that yeah
because you like you like predictability
and precision
well i do i i don't like a lot of risk
in my investments and then uh
you know i
with uh with the passive income i have
and the money i have the ira i'm i'm
doing okay yeah so i just don't know
that it's worth the risk not knowing
what's going to be in the mailbox when
you open it is not your play
right right and it is for some people
it's not free well i mean i own rental
property and i don't know if they're
going to pay every month
sure
and that but you know these tips are
paying yeah that that's a coupon it's
just going to show up in the dadgum
mailbox or the electronic mailbox
whatever i mean your money's coming you
can it's mailbox money you can count on
it so i i think your life is good and i
don't think i'd screw with it
because of the weight the way you take
if there's a few million here you might
say all right it's paying cash for
something that's what i'm looking for
but 800 000 i don't think it's worth
taking a huge chunk of that out to buy
real estate if you're sitting on 2
million in that i pull 500 out and move
it towards some kind of a commercial
real estate and you love real estate but
real estate is not for everyone and you
don't need it to build wealth and keep
wealth no people can do that with their
mutual funds with their 401ks and i do
it with a lot of things but you just
need to do it with something that that
fits your profile and he's got a very
clear profile
um and part of his profile is his
friends are not trustworthy
time to find new friends at 68 i don't
know you've had these friends for so
long well it's just we're all sitting on
the front porch whittling with an
opinion about economics but yeah
yeah
that's what friends are for that's what
wives are for too and husbands are for
it's good stuff we need them all very
good stuff
one of the keys to my wealth building
has been slowing down enough to make
sure my wife speaks into it sharon is
the best investment they've ever made
you heard it here first you did it's
absolutely 40 years now this is the
ramsey show